on aborde le tour de façon sereine c'est
vrai que on a des coureurs expérimentés
des couacs ont l'habitude de venir en
france autour de guadeloupe avec la
présence de ces délestages qui est quand
même un pilier un capitaine de route
pour la délégation on a des jeunes aussi
la personne de bandon ajax ayant décidé
dès que vous prononcez sur les hauteurs
du pays edhi michel cadé masquer un
jeune qui en devenir qu'un jeune qui a
bien marché sur le tour de martinique et
bien sûr stanislas et thierry ragots on
sait que le bois ne pas nous brosser
valeur une grosse seconde
c'était un bon repère bien sûr pour nos
c'est un repère un pour nous c'est que
c'est une case deux donc c'est une
équipe c'est une auto qui aura des
équipes de renom les équipes
internationales des équipes de niveau
professionnel
maintenant ça fait plusieurs années
qu'on bute au podium avec la personne de
cédric eustache qui fait comme ça fait
déjà deux fois 4e 3 5e on y va
on va dire motivés avec des ambitions
maintenant la course donnera aussi son
lot de surprises mais c'est vrai qu'on a
une équipe structurée n'est que motivés
avec des tâches que chacun devra
accomplir
quels sont les espoirs martinique et les
espérances et les espérances et comme
toute équipe invitée déjà faire honneur
au pays faire honneur à l'invitation
faire honneur
au maillot martinique est donc là bien
sûr je vais pas vous cacher qu'on essaie
de viser un podium maintenant c'est pas
chose facile
le vélo c'est pas sa peine sur c'est
exact donc on va se donner les moyens de
faire les choses bien et puis de se
faire plaisir on n'a pas le temps que
faire plaisir au public aux alpes et le
cantique 0 comptant pour la sélection de
martinique dont les tatouages et oui
c'est vrai que nous on a la chance de
de tout juste finir le tènement team et
qu'on a eu dix quinze jours de
récupération de régénération de
regroupement entre les coureurs
maintenant ce sont des causes qui ont
l'habitude de se côtoyer quand l'étude
déjà dévolue en sélection donc
normalement tout devrait bien se passer
et puis on est là pour déjà montré que
le cyclisme en tk progresser et puis
tenté de faire des belles choses